is Merrick garland Supreme Court worthy
and is it wrong to deny him even a
confirmation here Merrick garland who
was my classmate was one of the stars of
the section he was one of the gunners in
the class that would challenge the
professor's the entire year we all
looked up to him and a couple other
people who were like in that upper
echelon in a very very decent human
being would be a wonderful adherent to
the democratic constitution mm-hmm he is
a difference guy par excellence he
defers to the EPA he defers to
administrative agencies that guy defers
like crazy and for that reason as a
matter of judicial philosophy I think he
would not be a good justice for us to
have part of the problem is evaluating
justices on basis of quote so called
qualifications as long as everybody was
an agreement in the democratic
constitution the post new deal
understanding of what constitutions
should be which Republicans and
Democrats were all in agreement about
then at that point all you're interested
in is qualifications how smart are you
how good are you because everybody
basically agrees but now we have a
fundamental disagreement about the
Constitution starting with the Scalia
appointment and I mean to some extent
with Rehnquist but also Rehnquist and
Scalia then Thomas we have a
disagreement about the Constitution now
qualifications aren't enough what you
need is what Joe Biden used to say you
have to look for and that is judicial
philosophy and that gets us back to
original ism that is what a justice
should be an original list first and
foremost let me know in this and so let
me just say qualifications are necessary
but they're not sufficient is it
legitimate for the Republican Senate
essentially to forestall to run the
clock out is it legal to do that and I
guess it is but is it proper to do that
simply because you don't want to give
the sitting president it's every bit as
constitutional it means it's completely
constitutional in fact I haven't heard a
serious argument nope nobody makes a
serious argument that it's not
constitutionally permitted it's all an
argument about as you say whether it's
proper or not right and the Senate is is
entitled to veto or fail to consent to
an ignominious the president is to
select somebody this is what the Senate
did not the president did not select me
or someone like me he said
elected my classmate merit yeah and
therefore he discriminated against me he
chose he and he went with Merrick
instead and it's perfectly appropriate
for the Senate to say we disagree about
him and whether there needs to be a
hearing or not actually at that point I
would say there should not be a hearing
because given that we are in the
election cycle given that this
appointment is going to last far beyond
this president's tenure and it's
something that ought to be made an issue
at the next election is something that
the people as voters the electorate
should have a say-so in how this Court
is going to look in the future